2.4 billion women globally
are not afforded equal
economic opportunity.
In Brazil, women earn an average
of 30% less than men
and many are unbanked.
Most of the people in
Brazil are still unbanked
in the means of they don't have
fair interest rates, especially women.
The gender inequality is immense.
They don't have fair interest rates
and access to credit like immediately,
and they go to department
stores to get like credit
and the absurd interest rates
that they get is quite hard.
So I saw that challenge
and I told my dad like when I grow up,
I will develop that bank that
will give priority to women.
My name is Taynaah Reis.
I'm the CEO and founder of Moeda Seeds.
Moeda has been my mission in life.
I see as a legacy because my father
started doing microcredit a long time ago.
My father developed one of the largest
microcredit programs for
the agriculture-run families
and I would follow him everywhere
to the cooperatives, the
indigenous communities.
I see as well the potential
of technology to bring an idea
to its financial ecosystem
of social good and greatness.
My father gave my first
computer when I was one year old
and by the age of 12, I
was learning by myself
many programming languages.
I got to learn at a very young age
technology and how could I help
and improve people's lives.
The spark of helping women
came from a young age
because I saw the challenges
that they had to overcome,
especially because Brazil is a country.
A government report found that 43%
of Brazilian women have suffered violence
in their own homes.
According to UN figures,
a woman is assaulted every
15 seconds in Sao Paulo.
But this rampant misogyny
doesn't stop at home
and in the streets.
Women struggle for inclusion
in the financial system as well.
Six out of every 10 unbanked
Brazilians are women.
The bank guarantees that they have
are in the name of the
father into the family.
So I saw the challenge,
especially for women,
to have access to credit
and fair interest rates.
I see like that technology
would help both to do
transactions for them
to access capital and
people could see and trust
that their money and their
investments is doing good.
Blockchain is a technology
that allows people to create trust.
It holds information that is
crucial for people to measure
in our case the impact investment,
how many jobs we make
for each transaction,
and the impact on the environmental.
We use both blockchain and
artificial intelligence
to create a gamified way to
help women to access credit
with the mentorship and
the guidance we created
and develop a token that
incentivizes them along the way
and by them like hiring
more women and having KPIs
towards the social good
and impact that they do,
they can get discounts
on the interest rates
and a lot of more benefits
within the network.
The ecosystem Moeda
created allows for people
to access Moeda Pay,
a digital account that can be used
for making payments, bank transfers,
and transactions with
Bitcoin and other currency
with a specialized QR
code and credit card.
The MDA token was the first currency built
when Moeda was formed in 2017
and is currently the only
one that can be traded
in an open market or
directly between people.
The MDA token allows people
from all over the world to directly invest
in Moeda Seeds projects,
creating a global impact.
Their other currencies
are varying purposes.
MDABRL is used solely
within Moeda's ecosystem
for people not prepared
to endure the volatility
of the cryptocurrency market
while MDA loyal rewards
loyal social impact investors
with bonuses and incentives.
Once the women they decide
to partner with Moeda Seeds,
we offer them guidance and
mentorship, financial education,
literacy and entrepreneurship
program as well
that they can take and improve
their skills and abilities
and how to develop their small
and medium sized businesses.
Five years ago talking
about blockchain technology
and social impact investment
was quite challenging,
but today is easier.
I saw the spark on their eyes
and quite early the demand of
investments with a purpose.
The impact goes among 150,000 users
and more than one million
in capital deployed
along 28 beautiful
projects that we support.
Taynaah is in the process
of raising additional funds
to expand to over 2,000
projects in other regions
in the hope of multiplying
an impact to millions.
I had many entrepreneurs from
the Latin America region.
They have the same
challenges within Brazil,
the financial education,
the access to credit,
they all need that.
Moeda seeds is ready to scale and grow.
Many times I thought that
was impossible to achieve.
When you think not only about yourself,
when you think about the
others and how technology
can be a tool to help and
transform people's lives,
all the universe can conspire
for you to achieve your goals and dreams.